what they asked us to graph is this - or
square okay so we're going to do this
one step at a time and actually can't
borrow a pencil from someone the cyber
spear the reason why I'm going to do
this is um when you're graphing honestly
you should always try to graph in in
pencil because even even with this thing
you know you can still make mistakes or
maybe you didn't make a mistake but you
wouldn't adjust it for later on and
obviously much easier to do but secondly
what I'm about to show you to do is
almost impossible in pen because you
could do things lightly with pencil it's
very hard to do things like that I mean
you can try you can't sort it but it's
much easier with this so say yeah it's
negative what okay all right
so the first thing we're gonna do let's
draw opposite axis okay and then we can
start to put up in sponsors let's make
it reasonably large because as you can
see that parabola that we've been
drawing with it's quite large and you
want to have space for the hole
all right so again we're going to begin
with instead of this which is a mess
this is really hard and complicated
we're just going to start with x squared
okay and because you know how we had
this before right and it's like oh man
it's confusing there's so many graphs
there right so there's to distinguish
between them these these first graphs
I'm going to draw them in nice and
lightly so you'll hardly be able to see
them but but you'll be able to know that
they're there and then work from them
okay so let's start with x squared we
know where it goes we know which way
it's facing and we know where the vertex
the turning point is okay so pop it
there on the origin and draw it nice and
lightly if you got pencil then be brave
nah it's alright you just fits okay
there you go it's just barely good okay
so there's this y equals x squared right
and I'll just lightly so you can see I
have it I haven't put it in as far as I
as I will put the final graph okay now
we've done y equals x squared right
but what I want to get to is minus X
minus 6 squared so I'm gonna change it
one step at a time until I get to that
final graph so here's the first thing
I'm going to do I'm going to put in that
minus six okay like so so I'm going to
compare this graph to this graph right
so what's the difference it's moved it's
moved six units which direction isn't
going in okay think carefully is the Y
being changed or is the X being changed
it's the X it's the X so it's gonna be a
left-right change
okay now this bits confusing it's a
minus six so you actually move to the
right and if you're unsure about this
again you can just do a table of values
and check it all never let you down it
just takes longer so what we want to try
to avoid is is unnecessary working if we
can so I put a marketing for myself
which says move 6 units to the right
you can just see that okay move
succeeded so that's what it means
all right so I'm going to take this
graph see how the turning points at the
origin
you should have put in my labels there
right so now my toe you put will not be
at the origin it will be six units to
the right of the origin okay so let's
take think again now this this graph
it's usually the scale one centimeter is
one unit okay so I am actually going to
go six centimeters to the right and
maybe you don't have enough space on
yours which means maybe you put it
adjust or you can try and use a more
compressed scale it's up to you alright
so I've moved six units to the right I'm
going to draw my new one like so try and
line it up nicely it's pretty close
there we go okay so I can't see the
whole thing but I've got enough of an
idea of the shape right and like I said
it's in quite lightly and there's six
because remember I moved six units to
the right there I go
so this graph is y equals X minus 6
squared okay
jeonse a question
why would it go up so that's if I am
that's if you have a look at this
previous question right if I add a
number on the outside like this right
but you see this nut blows on the inside
of the brackets you see it
the wires okay right so you picked up a
good thing which is that on my scale
right I will hit the x-axis but sorry
the y-axis but where will I hit it and
the answer is way up here like I'm gonna
this graph keeps going this is just as
far as I've drawn it right so it
actually does keep going and it will
collide if I kept going on the problem
is the place will collide is actually at
36 units which as you can see is not on
my graph like I'd have to go you know
36 centimeters up this axis to get there
so my graph is not big enough to show
that okay all right that's okay we can
still keep going so what have I done I
have started with x squared that was
step one then I moved it across I
shifted it six units that was the second
thing yeah okay
in fact I would too if I had a bit of
extra space up here can you see they
would keep going and they were here but
I just my graph is not big as big as
yours okay so that's why it's fine I
have one last thing to do before I
actually graph the graph I was meant to
get to at the end so this is my third
and last step okay I need to slap a
minus sign on the front of everything
okay does that make sense so I started
with this I've moved it to the right now
remind me we just looked at this what
does that minus sign at the front what
does that do good turn it upside down
it's a frowny okay so and this is my
final graph yeah so I'm gonna do this
one ferma I'm doing going to do as high
as I can and it's this graph this one
here but it's been turned upside down
that's the difference okay so you take
your template you turn it around pop it
on the right spot
why cause x squared so this is kind of
the the simplest parabola that there is
a little bit like that it's kind of like
your starting point I think it is there
you go yep
so now I'm done you can see my
difference by the way thank you -
Naomi's pencil I started with this x
squared nice and light
then I moved it over also nice and light
and then when I got to my final one now
you can tell when you look at this even
though there are three graphs you can
tell which one is the most important one
and so I'm gonna label that because it's
so important I'm gonna label it in here
just got serious
okay there you go done one other piece
of important information which the
question asks for where is the turning
point what are the coordinates of the
vertex and you can see them there right
the value is 6 on one of the what are
the coordinates I I need brackets and I
need two numbers yeah well done six
units across and zero units up all right
so that's the vertex and it's it's it's
right